[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>>> WHAT THE -- OW!
>> SLEEP TIGHT, OLD MAN.
I'M IN.
>> AND WE'RE IN BUSINESS.
I'M GOING TO WORK ON GETTING
THOSE SECURITY DOORS OPEN FOR
YOU.
SHOULDN'T BE LONG NOW, BOSS.
>> FANTASTIC.
I'LL LET THE CLIENT KNOW.
THEY'RE IN.
>> IMPRESSIVE, MR. KNIGHT.
BUT MY BOSS DOESN'T PAY YOU TO
GET INSIDE UNDERGROUND GARAGE.
HE PAY YOU TO STEAL
BILLIONAIRE'S VINTAGE
LAMBORGHINI.
IS THERE, YES?
>> GHOST, YOU GOT EYES ON THE
PRIZE?
>> OH, YEAH.
SHE'S ONE BAD BITCH.
>> OKAY, GHOST.
YOU GOT TWO MINUTES TO GET OUT
THERE.
YOU'RE WELCOME, BY THE WAY.
>> TWO MINUTES?
I'M GOING TO COUNT MY MONEY IN
ONE.
LET'S DO THIS.
>> HA HA HA!
>> EVERYTHING ALL RIGHT, GHOST?
>> YEAH, YEAH.
JUST, YOU KNOW -- A CAR LIKE
THIS IS LIKE A BEAUTIFUL LADY.
JUST GOT TO KNOW HOW TO HANDLE
HER.
WHAT THE HELL?
>> OH, YEAH, BOSS.
I THINK WE GOT A PROBLEM.
>> WHAT'S GOING ON, GHOST?
>> THIS CAR GOT AN ADVANCE
DRIVER SYSTEM I'VE NEVER SEEN
BEFORE.
I'M LOOKING AT
THREE PEDALS, A SHIFTER THAT
GOES UP, DOWN, AND SIDE WAYS.
THIS MUST BE SOME NEW TECH, I'M
THINKING.
MILITARY, MAYBE?
>> SOUNDS LIKE IT'S A STICK
SHIFT?
>> STICK WHAT?
>> A STICK SHIFT.
GHOST, YOU CAN DRIVE STICK,
RIGHT?
>> BITCH, I CAN DRIVE ANYTHING.
>> INCLUDING STICK?
>> NAH.
>> GHOST, I'LL WALK YOU THROUGH
THIS.
ANYTHING YOU DON'T GET, YOU SAY
STOP.
>> COOL.
>> TURN THE CAR ON AND PRESS THE
CLUTCH.
>> STOP.
YOU SAID CLUCK?
>> HA HA HA!
THE BOY SAID CLUCK!
>> SHUT UP, OLD MAN.
>> PUT THE CAR IN GEAR.
>> STOP.
>> WE DON'T HAVE TIME.
STOP, PUT IT IN GEAR, PRESS THE
GAS WITH YOUR RIGHT FOOT.
>> STOP, YOU WANT ME TO DRIVE
WITH TWO FEET?
WHO DO YOU THINK I AM, FRED
FLINTSTEIN?
>> FLINTSTEIN?
>> DID I STITTER?
FREDERICK FLINTSTEIN.
>> 60 SECONDS.
>> ENOUGH.
MR. GHOST, THIS IS NATALIA.
I HELP, SO LISTEN, YES?
>> YES, MA'AM.
>> LEFT FOOT CLUTCH, RIGHT FOOT
GAS.
>> DOWN, BABY GIRL.
>> TAKE FOOT OFF CLUTCH AND GIVE
GAS.
>> COPY.
>> AND GIVE GAS.
>> IMPOSSIBLE.
>> THEN DRIVE.
IS CLEAR?
>> NAH, BUT LET'S DO THIS.
>> WE'LL HAVE TO GO A LOT FASTER
THAN THAT, GHOST.
>> GOOD THING THIS BABY HAS
NITROUS BOOSTERS.
>> THAT'S THE TRUNK!
>> GET OUT OF THERE RIGHT NOW,
GHOST, OR YOU'RE DEAD, MAN.
>> DON'T YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T KILL
A GHOST.
>> HE AIN'T GONNA MAKE IT.
HEY, BUMPS, WE GOT A PROBLEM.
[ APPLAUSE ]